now to a story about an ongoing
nightmare for the families of Sandy Hook
shooting victims radio talk show host
Alex Jones has taken the stand in
another defamation trial that will
determine how much he owes Sandy Hook
families for spreading lies about the
massacre he stands to lose Millions but
Jones was defiant angrily answering
questions as the families looked on
ikibati says more on the heated
exchanges
Alex Jones faced the families of Sandy
Oak victims and has returned to a
Connecticut courtroom where a six-member
jury will determine just how much he
should pay them he was found liable of
defamation by default last year for his
failure to produce documents I'm done
saying I'm sorry but I legitimately
thought it might have been staged and I
stand by that I don't apologize for it
and don't apologize Mr Jones Thursday's
proceedings were full of outlandish
claims from the Infowars host more than
a dozen victims relatives were in
attendance and visibly emotional some
testified earlier in the week that
they'd been harassed because of the lies
Jones promoted people were accusing me
of lying telling me Ben never lived
uh telling me that I was going to burn
in hell Jones has referred to the
defamation trial as a kangaroo court and
to its judge as a tyrant can you
actually use that word a lot with your
audience you call people tyrants don't
you
only when they act like it the judge
would be fully within her rights in
throwing Alex Jones in jail for the
contempt that he's shown in court Alex
talbes is a connecticut-based civil
rights attorney when he would lie about
the families of Sandy Hook he would make
millions of dollars as a result of it
and the jury in Connecticut can consider
whether he has to pay back in
restitution the money that he profited
off of their pain and suffering for CBS
mornings I'm Nikki Batiste
so sorry families are still dealing with
this